donc
la guerre est finie, les
gens avaient très peur de ce qui
s'était passé après la première guerre mondiale
après la seconde
qui était une pauvreté énorme je ne pense pas que les
gens étaient avides de beaucoup de choses
ces jours-là, ils voulaient juste vivre en
paix avoir un  le travail du
travail a remporté une victoire écrasante et ces
mineurs endurcis les larmes
coulaient sur leurs joues ils
nous ont sortis d'une époque
où le pot était répandu quand la maladie
sévissait
le gouvernement travailliste n'a pas seulement logé des
gens, ils les ont bien logés sont
venus thatcher et tout à coup c'était
tout  à propos de l'individu
l'idée du socialisme est faible dans ce
pays et l'idée du capitalisme est
très forte
qui leur dit de me battre un ouvrier
avec un bâton en fait nous devrions recommencer
à travailler ensemble
pour le plus grand bien un jour je pense que
le rêve  deviendra une réalité et nous
pourrons prendre
le contrôle réel de nos propres vies la génération plus âgée
a le devoir absolu de se manifester
et de se joindre aux jeunes et de
commencer t  parler
de ce qu'était la vision en 1945
vous